Well,
let me lay on you.
One.
Libertarianism is to me,
once again,
I'm speaking for myself,
which is about as libertarian is you can
get,
I do not believe I know what's best for
other people.
I also don't believe that other people
know what's best for other people.
I can barely make decisions for myself.
I do my best to make decisions for my
family.
Shouldn't my 10 year old son take music
lessons?
That's a hard question for our family.
You want to push them into it or wait
until he really wants it.
It was a hard decisions.
I have trouble making those for my
family,
so making the decision of what someone
else's job and healthcare should be
like.
It was in another part of the country
who I've never met is not something I'm
qualified or desire is to do.
That's libertarianism.
Libertarianism is taking a right on
money and your first left on sex and
looking for utopia straight ahead to me.
The way I was brought up western
Massachusetts,
kind of a New England philosophy,
we believed in responsibility and
keeping your nose out of other people's
business.
We believed in live and let live,
I think to a fault.
Um,
my mom and dad were older parents too.
My mom was 45 and I was born,
so I was raised by another generation.
She,
my mom was,
my mom would be,
whatever,
120 now or 115 now,
um,
whole of the generation.
My mom was born.
Now you're going to see that my math is
wrong.
My mom was born in 1909.
Uh,
she's dead now.
Um,
so it's a whole different generation.
And my mom's feeling about absolutely
everything was,
who cares?
Uh,
her whole feeling I'm the gay rights
movement was who cares who they wanted
get together with.
It doesn't matter to me.
Her whole feeling on drugs.
I have never had a sip of alcohol or any
recreational drug in my life.
That was true for my mother too,
from my father too,
for my sister.
I don't know how many generations that
goes back,
but never.
And yet my mom always thought that,
sure,
any drugs should be legal.
If you're,
if you're living in a free country,
do whatever you want.
Um,
take responsibility for it.
When you tell people about
libertarianism,
um,
you just tell them we think you should
take as little from other people by
force as possible and you should be able
to do whatever you think is right.
Now that's a pretty heavy thing I'm
saying because I'm saying that if
there's an 18 year old girl who was the
greatest math wiz that we have in this
country,
let's say she's the smartest person at
math.
We have anywhere.
And let's say we give her a full
scholarship to go to whatever school she
wants to go to,
Stanford,
mit or wherever she wants to go.
And she decides she wants to work at
Mcdonald's and get pregnant
at the age of 19.
That's her decision.
Jim Morrison,
did he have a worse life because he did
an awful lot of drugs and died at 28.
I don't know.
I've already lived a lot longer than Jim
Morrison.
Boy,
his choices worse than mine.
I Dunno.
I know.
I would not have liked to have lived
like Jim Morrison,
although I'd like to look that good and
leather pants.
But,
um,
Kurt cobain did that.
I want to live like that.
No,
not even slightly prince.
I don't want to live like that.
Uh,
but uh,
they probably don't want to live like me
either.
Um,
libertarianism is the strongest sense of
please do what you want.
Try not to hurt me.
Our government has a monopoly on force,
have a monopoly on force.
The government is the only organization
that is supposed to be able to use for
us.
The government is supposed to be a
government
of us,
which means in my thinking,
my morality,
the government should only use force for
things I'm willing to use.
Force for the government are the only
ones that are allowed to use guns to
hurt another person or threatened
another person legally for the question
becomes,
what would I use a gun
to do?
No,
I'm a coward and I have no skills with
guns,
with violence.
I've never hit a person in anger in my
life.
I've been hit.
I've never hit back.
So this is hypothetical,
but if I were not a coward,
would I use a gun to stop someone from
being killed?
Yes,
but he used a gun to stop from being
raped.
Yes.
What?
I use a gun to build the library.
I take money from someone to build the
library.
Well,
I'd certainly give my money.
I certainly work.
I'd certainly beg you for money to build
the library.
Library's really mattered to me.
Um,
I was born in 55 and from a small town
without a library,
I would have known nothing.
I had to drive to them.
I had to ride my bike to the library to
learn about Lenny Bruce Franz Kafka.
Uh,
I got stravinsky records in the library
meant everything to me.
A library is matter,
but
that's the libertarian question.
Now,
taking care of people.
Would you use a gun to take care of
others?
Um,
that's a hard one because taxation is
using violence.
Now people try to say taxation is
voluntary.
It's not.
If you don't pay your taxes,
eventually somewhere down the line,
someone with a gun will show up.
They just will some at some point.
If you don't do that.
Um,
what do we do with our taxes?
We used a gun to defend our country.
Yeah,
I guess we got it right.
Um,
but we use a gun for everything we use
for taxes.
So when I see the government doing
something,
I asked myself,
would I use a gun to do that?
Now all of that being said,
that is a high level.
The theoretical part of libertarianism
to me in a nuts and bolts level becomes
much,
much simpler.
This is one of the cases where the,
the reality is simpler than the,
uh,
than the theory.
When someone's worried about
libertarianism,
they worry about what happens to public
schools.
What happens to a welfare,
what happens to roads?
Those are the first three questions they
ask.
And those are the hardest questions.
I will give you public schools.
I will give you welfare.
I will give you infrastructure.
I will not give you the government using
a gun to take money from poor people and
giving it to rich people.
The biggest issue in libertarianism is
stopping corporate welfare.
What we give in welfare to the poor,
we give in government money to the
roads.
We give him money.
Giving money to the schools is nothing
compared to the money we give to rich
people.
The best way to stop crony capitalism,
the West way to stop graft,
the best way to stop,
uh,
all sorts of bad stuff in government is
to make government small enough.
The way you stop corruption is make it
small enough to corruption.
Doesn't pay,
give the government little enough that
there's not a lot to steal from them.
The government is buoying up the rich
corporations.
The rich corporations love the
government.
They gain the system in a way.
An individual never can.
Any big corporation has a team of the
best lawyers to figure out how they can
not pay taxes.
No middle class person has that.
They have all,
they have regulations set to keep other
people out of the business,
right?
Even the manicure shops,
you know,
they want to license,
register everything so that,
so that other people can't get in.
It's limiting.
If you had a true free market,
you would not have the big mega
corporations.
Uh,
libertarianism is not about rich white
people getting a lot of money for
corporations and leaving everybody else
to whistle.
Libertarianism is,
let's not use the government to take
money from poor people and middle class
people and give it to rich people
because really that's all that's ever
happened.
That's all that's ever happened in our
present,
uh,
climate.
We have somebody running for president
who we know for a fact lied,
lied a lot less than other people.
We know for a fact she lied and we know
for a fact that she is an insider and
that knows the way to play all the
games.
Uh,
we also know that she knows what's
better for other people.
I mean know that she says and claims and
brags that she will do a lot of killing
of people overseas.
We also know that she is essentially,
even if I've called her a liar,
she's essentially a good,
honest person,
but she essentially has a good heart.
She also has a 65% disapproval rating or
higher.
That's Hillary Clinton.
There were two things that I always
believed about modern politics.
One was that
everyone who would ever run for a major
office was smarter than me.
And the second thing was there was no
one worse than Hillary Clinton.
Both of those things have been disproven
by Donald Trump.
Donald Trump,
all the good qualities I mentioned about
Hillary Clinton.
Donald Trump does not share.
He's not skilled.
He does not have as I far as I can tell
any compassion.
Um,
and he,
uh,
does not have very much knowledge.
Uh,
he does have a weird kind of a charisma
that I cannot understand myself.
It doesn't seem to work on me,
but certainly demonstrative that he has
a charisma that works for some people
and he's willing to give easy answers
and being willing to give easy answers,
which in his case aren't answers,
they're just,
I will fix it.
We've got this problem.
I'll fix it.
Well,
no,
you don't get to say that.
You have to demonstrate how you're doing
it.
But both Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump
are very interested in getting a lot of
power for themselves.
I believe Hillary Clinton wants that
power cause she thinks she knows what's
best for other people.
Let's refer back to me saying,
I don't know what's best for other
people.
I also don't think she does either,
but she believes that,
and I believe heart's in the right
place.
I don't think Donald Trump knows there
are other people,
um,
to be concerned about.
I don't think he even knows that you've
got those two and neither one of them as
this is not fair to Hillary Clinton.
Donald Trump is giving no,
uh,
theoretical policy ideas for how
government should run.
Hillary Clinton is not giving enough for
my taste.
Here's their bed.
I want to see
not even a debate conversation,
public conversation in front of as much
of America's wants to watch it.
Bernie Sanders,
Gary Johnson,
both paragons,
both virtuous,
both honest,
both smart,
both concerned about other people,
both his experience in government.
And I want to hear Bernie Sanders say,
you know,
lot of people in this country have
trouble taking care of themselves.
We need a strong infrastructure for
business to thrive.
We need to protect our country to
protect the people around us.
We need a big strong government with a
good solid safety net that can take care
of people and treat them with compassion
and they better choices than some
individuals will make.
We need a government were more
qualified.
People can take care of those that
aren't and where we can keep
corporations at bay and where we can
keep some money out of politics.
That's what we need.
And here's some examples of how we can
get there from where we are.
Here are the the a checks and balances
we want to put in place on,
on corporations.
Here's what to do with campaign finance
here.
Here's what we want to do with schools
Some of my ideas,
but I want to Gary Johnson to say,
you know,
all those things are problems,
but I think that maybe a little more
freedom as opposed to a little more
control from the government might give
us a lot of that.
I want individuals to have a little more
money in their pockets and use that for
charity and use that for building.
And I think instead of putting up
tariffs to keep foreigners foreign
businesses out,
uh,
we can actually make America more
competitive,
uh,
less of less taxes and let them have
more power that way and be more
successful and to be more money all over
the place.
We can take care of people.
I think that will work pretty well.
And while we're at it,
we'll stop the corporations by not
having a big government,
the flows money to them.
And then Bernie Sanders says back,
you know,
that sounds really good,
gary really does.
But there are some people who just plain
are going to be left out.
They're not gonna make it.
They're just not going to make it in
your Doggie dog free market economy.
You just got a little willing to throw
them away.
And then Gary says,
well,
you know,
maybe a,
a
maybe a subsistence amount of money for
everybody.
Maybe just get paid.
Just give him that money cause you know,
compare to what we're playing for food
stamps and all of that stuff.
Just writing them a check as much
easier.
So maybe we can do that.
And Bernie says,
you know what you're saying about
keeping businesses over here kind of
makes sense.
Uh,
Gary,
maybe we can do a few left less tariffs
and a little lower taxes to help our
corporations.
And maybe that'll help a little bit.
And they go back and forth and they cope
with an impasse where they don't agree.
And then the American people say,
you know,
let's try it Bernie's way for awhile.
Let's give it four years of burning
because it seems like he,
he's got some ideas.
Let's go.
Four years of burning.
You know,
Gary,
you're a good guy.
You thought about this really hard and
he made a really good case and we know
you're a good guy.
We like,
can we trust you?
But we're going with burning now.
And we tried that for awhile and is
Bernie's doing this?
There's other people in the government
that go,
what about this?
And he pulls back on this and he adjusts
and he does that.
And then he comes,
uh,
you know,
four years go by and the country goes,
let's hear that debate again.
Maybe someone else in place,
but whatever the hear the debate again
and they go,
you know,
we tried.
We don't really feel your burn.
Now feel my Johnson.
We'll have,
we'll have Gary Johnson take over for
four years.
See how that goes.
And you go back and forth and you have a
discussion of what we want to do as a
country between two good,
honest,
hard thinking human beings.
And please let's get one of them to be a
woman by the next time we do this
please.
And let's get someone to be of color.
Please.
Let's just do that.
We've got plenty of people on both sides
that aren't just white guys.
But for right now,
my example,
uh,
Bernie and,
and,
and Gary,
and we go back and forth like that.
Why aren't we doing that?
Why do we have two people that all they
agree on is that they should have power
to psychotic power,
hungry,
hated,
unpleasant people clawing and scratching
to take power over other people's lives?
Why not two people who are actually
having a discussion about what direction
our country should go in?
And by the way,
we're never going to go all the way,
Bernie.
We're never going to go all the way,
Gary.
But that's the discussion we have and
let that go.
So that is what I think about modern
politics.
And that's when I think about
libertarianism.
Yeah.
Maybe someday in the future we should go
to and arco capitalism.
to full out socialism.
But for right now,
can we just do what every mother fucking
American believes,
which is stop giving so much money to
the corporations.
Let the people have more control,
let them spoke dope.
Let them put what they want into their
bodies.
Let them have sex with whoever they want
as long as there's consent.
And let them do that in every state.
Let them love who they want and enjoy
life the way they want.
Life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
Is that enough position?